I loved the film what's it been like now
that it's you know we're doing this for
the blu-ray release and yeah it's been
out do you feel you know I think
probably before some may have seen as a
risk to be like oh it's fantasy oh it's
all rated but do you feel like
vindicated now that the film has been so
well received I've really felt like I
was challenging people too much or that
I had something to prove I think it's
just the nature of this project the
nature of this film and this story and
this this person that we're kind of
looking at and how we how we chose to
tell that story it's it's I didn't hit
many naysayers so it's to feel
vindicated by you don't mean it I I
think then there may have been a desire
for it to be something different for
what it was but those things were
irrelevant because oh and myself David
Furnish Matthew Vaughn Taran we were at
a very strong a particular idea and then
I had a vision for it that I was able to
fulfill in in my best possible way so
that's what's exciting about it that's
what's engaging about it and hopefully
that there's an appetite for that as
much as there's an appetite for
something that's because this is you
know there's not a lot of our writing
musicals around and I think that was
something that we were really excited
about this is our strength this is what
we buy into and and maybe we can offer
something different you know this is
it's also an unusual musical in that you
know it's not that every musical number
is big and flashy it highs and lows yeah
can you talk a little bit about sort of
approaching that where you have
something like Saturday nights alright
where it is sort of a big number but
then something like your song where it's
just it's just you know at the piano
yeah
oh the numbers of different inverts
they're doing different things within
the story and sometimes they are all out
fantasy and they're just a celebration
of a moment and a feeling they're all
about feelings I suppose really
essentially and and and as we know those
things are varied and completely calm
and different and sometimes you know for
me your song is like the one moment in
the film when it's just actually the
moment of the song being written and if
you took away all the other fantasy
moments that man would still be there
that song would still be there because
it's a seminal moment in open and
Bernie's life is all not only about
their friendship but as a month where an
incredible song touch millions of people
is written and created so that would
still be there whereas you could argue
certainly nights alright for a fire is
about a young man discovering the wider
world thinking I want to get out there
there's all these interesting people and
influences music the that's fantasy
so you yeah you could take that away and
it still it still worked dramatically so
but they're all different in summer
performances something's out there on
stage and he's doing you know bending
the Jets that then becomes a fantasy
thing as well and so with Rocket Man so
I try to make them all do something
different but still speak to how Ellen
is feeling at that particular moment in
the story and I think well the things I
like about the film is that it doesn't
really because that fantasy approach
lets all kind of blend together were
there any sort of thoughts about like do
we want to say it is now 1977 no do we
want to you know delineate time more
clearly or should we just let it flow as
it yeah yeah I mean having made biopics
before that's a bit of a trap you know
it can be and and the thing is you could
never really satisfy in two hours
thirty years of a life and you have to
play fast and loose with with with facts
and timelines and people and and
locations and all that sort of stuff so
I kind of chose to embrace that and say
it's just what happened over a period of
time and also because it's Ellen is our
narrator he's kind of remembering things
you know memories are fallible thing you
know it's it's based in emotion it's not
really always based in fact and and so
that means if I were to turn this story
my life I would get things wrong but I
would be I tell you what the story of my
life was still
you just things get mixed up and that's
okay and I took that kind of as part of
the rules if you like that things were
going to be wrong but that's almost sort
of intentional that he sort of puts
things in the wrong order or the wrong
persons there or because it's really
about how we felt and how it moved him
to the next stage of his life now you're
also attached now to Sherlock Holmes
three and having previously worked with
guy if you talk with him at all about
moving into that that series like you're
gonna have a great time go you know go
go and have a great time it'll be
exciting Roberts fantastic Jude's
amazing that's an incredible incredible
cast there and a great opportunity and
he's not around to do it he's off you
know doing what he's doing so it feels
good to be part of that you know guy and
I go way back and and he's he's very
generous and sort of I think if I take a
lot of fun it's me
do you want to sort of continue his
style or do you want to sort of try to
bring a new stamp to that I'm not going
to kind of ignore what he did so
brilliantly before I would also bring my
own voice to it as well and it will be
something sort of you know different and
I suppose that's the idea of bringing in
somebody new we'll see what happens
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with me too I really appreciate it